alright let's talk a little bit about
immigration we actually have not done
much about immigration on this show and
I saw a rasmussen survey that was really
interesting about what Americans think
about immigration right now so let's
look at some numbers seventy-eight
percent of likely us voters believe
everyone should be required to prove his
or her citizenship before being allowed
to register to vote twenty-nine percent
believe laws that require proof of
citizenship before allowing voter
registration discriminates against such
voters and 61 percent say laws do not
discriminate up three points from this
time last year okay so as I said we have
not done a tremendous amount on
immigration so I'm glad that we're
talking about this and this is one of
these things that it's always an issue
and we sometimes talk about it a little
bit more and then suddenly we forget
about it and it's hard to figure out
which parties for what the seventy eight
percent let's just talk about that yeah
that seems pretty legit to me that
basically eighty percent of the country
saying you should at least be able to
prove your citizenship to vote does that
seem like a sort of baseline way to
start well I think it seems like we've
been discussing it so much in the media
in a fear-based way but when you really
look at the numbers for things like
voter fraud they're so incredibly
minuscule it really isn't a huge problem
but we've kind of now made it this whole
immigration issue in a fear-based issue
more than an actual election issue but
the reality of the matter is it it does
requiring this kind of voter ID it does
and will continue to discriminate
against women against people who are in
lower income brackets against the
elderly and and the majority of this is
all political because the people who
that it affects do tend to vote so if
you look at this it's happening in red
state it's happening in red states all
right before I let you jump in Jimmy
what what's the rationale because this
is what people say all the time about
why why is it that having IDs would
discriminate against women and mine are
well one of the reasons is because it
costs money to end up getting those IDs
it whether it's a birth certificate that
you have to use if you have to have a
copy of a birth certificate that costs
money you know fifteen dollars twenty
bucks
costs money to get a driver's license it
costs money to get a passport and it
also requires transportation to certain
offices in order to get some of these
documents and that can be discriminatory
against people who don't have the funds
to do that I understand the idea of
being registered to vote I understand
the idea of making sure that voter fraud
isn't a problem but really if you look
at it it hasn't been a huge problem so
okay so I'm so I get all that for sure
but I basically agree with the the
people that say you should at least have
to prove that you're legally in this
country to vote am I a crazy
conservative on this issue ways well I
mean you have to prove your ID that
you're 21 to buy beer so I don't think
saying that just proving that you live
in this country my sister might not a
guarantee right in the Constitution
right so that's read the difference
there but uh III think that if you want
you are I mean once I was informed about
the ramifications of a voter ID law I
was against the voter ID law because
they know they can scientifically prove
that it's going to it's going to
eliminate a certain percentage of people
from voting for all the reasons she just
said right because they're poor and they
don't have access right right people
like well I got an ID well some people
don't there's a 90 year old woman who's
been voting her whole life and she
doesn't have transportation and she
doesn't have money and she lives on a
fixed income and she doesn't have access
to get to that stuff but she can vote
and they'll say but no you can vote now
because we're not gonna you can't do
these certain things that we're gonna
change so uh there is again this is a
solution in search of a problem there is
no voter uh there is no voter of fraud
nobody's going voting twice it's not
happening so the only reason you would
want to implement this is to do is to
make sure you tilt the favor and took in
favor of the Republicans and you
discriminate against some of the
Democrat votes that's the only reason
you would do this and to that point it
does seem that the Republicans are the
ones that want this all to happen all
these voter ID things so they're not
doing it at the goodness of the country
they're doing it every different taste
bring it write your thank-you Kansas
Arizona North Carolina yes yes it's just
like the guy from Pennsylvania we've
seen that clip a bunch of times with a
guy said a voter ID which is going to
guarantee the state of Pennsylvania for
Mitt Romney done you've seen that clip
that's why they do it then pretend
again the news media pretending that
it's a legitimate argument or not or
exactly what they're doing isn't voter
suppression that why isn't every
reporter screaming from the top of their
lungs about voter suppression in America
it's because they're bought and paid for
and they don't want to piss off half the
people who want to suppress the vote
right so what would you guys say to Bill
O'Reilly who's on TV every night saying
that if they if you let these immigrants
that are already in the country the
people that are here illegally but they
are acting as us if you let them in they
all vote Democratic it will be the end
of the Republican Party which may in a
weird way be bad for our political
system if we really only became a one
political thing even though we're pretty
much a one political thing is is but
what would you say to that argument I
would say that is that's just fear
mongering that's just trying to scare
people into believing that there's a
problem that really just isn't a problem
you know if they're they're making the
discussion about something that isn't a
huge issue there are so many other
things that we should be focusing on and
talking about and this is a way to try
to maintain control in in these very red
states yeah and also ninety-five percent
of the people that are here even if
they're here illegally are perfectly
legal people within our borders you know
I mean they're working jobs and have
families I i know people personally who
had families split up and people been
deported that can't see their children
for 20 years I mean all kinds of son
Bill O'Reilly says well we can't let all
these immigrants come here because
they're gonna vote Democratic and the
Republican Party well what that really
means is hey there's a bunch of people
are we're gonna have to appeal to with
our policies now that we don't want to
have to appeal to with our policies so
we can just not keep them away from
voting so we can just keep on appealing
to a narrower and narrower base of
people that's exactly what they're
saying oh my god we're gonna have to
address the reality that what we want
America isn't what most people want in
America holy [ __ ] yes then you should
have to change your problem your party's
a platform or you go away right and the
thing is in America we're all children
or grandchildren or great-grandchildren
of immigrant give us your tired your
poor your huddled masses somehow we
don't want any more so final thought of
this because obviously we talk about
immigration forever but what do you
think about securing the border because
that does seem like a legitimate
argument to me at least that first
somehow we should be able to secure the
border
then you know to stop new immigrants
from coming in illegally while we deal
with the issue not that we ever do
anything in a correct order but at least
I cat that argument at least make some
sense to me ah well yeah I mean one of
the it's a it's it's definitely an
important issue to think about we have
all of the the legislation really in
place to deal with illegal immigration
we just don't have a lot of real
enforcement we are we are backwards we
all we do do things kind of in the in
the wrong way we do approach things in a
in a cart before the horse kind of way
when it comes to an immigration is one
of them when it comes to things like
immigrate Chris for the last five years
we could have been dealing with border
issues just deal with figuring out how
do we secure the border and then say
okay we've dealt with that now we can
deal with the people who are here and
the people who want to get in but we
never deal with anything in the correct
order well no of course that well it's
it's because there's this crazy you know
dual info interests right so
corporations big farming corporations
egg egg we're business they want a cheap
labor but then they don't want them to
be able to vote so they can vote into a
union right so they it's that push they
want them here to work but they don't
want to treat them like human beings
right this part with the legislation
like there are people who are here and
people are willingly paying them under
the table and paying them tax free and
those laws aren't being enforced because
there are so many big corporations who
are benefiting from that kind of thing
so that it's already there we've
established what see illegal but it we
aren't necessarily enforcing it because
there's a benefit that that is the
you're right Jimmy about the the irony
of the Republicans because especially
the Mexicans that come in they work at
jobs that Americans don't seem to work
and they bust their asses for 18 hours a
day doing the hardest labor-intensive
jobs and then they don't get much for
return and that's good for the
corporations and really we know the lazy
Mexicans coming in here taking our jobs
taking our jobs they want this gig but
um I'm keeping it people
you